europe is a place of pilgrimage
and we don't think of it that way but
we should
you have more tourists in europe than
you have citizens
and the question is well why is that
and the answer is very straightforward
it's beauty period the end
and
especially for someone from new york but
or from north america but from any more
modern place
coming to europe is nourishing in an
extraordinarily deep way to see these
old
communities and these beautiful
buildings
it's
necessary it's not
it's not optional that's why people
spend so much money doing it and that's
why they work to be able to do it they
work
at things they don't want to do to be
able to come and
spend a week in paris or a week in milan
or
a weekend
you have enjoyed your time here it's
beautiful that old town is so beautiful
it's crazily beautiful and
i i'm i'm
it's concerning
the more modern europe becomes the more
it looks generic
and
as an economic decision that's it's so
foolish you have this immense heritage
of stunning beauty and it's it's almost
incalculably financially worthwhile it's
like capitalize on that that's what you
have to offer the world and it's
something it's something it's not power
and dominion and oppression and
it the oppressive imperial patriarchy
that's not it at all it's
at minimum it's beauty and beauty well
that's dostoyevsky's line beauty will
save the world absolutely and my final
question is we have really made lots of
work
to make our country beautiful
town beautiful but we are afraid of
russia yeah they may come and reconquer
again and i have a question which you
may or may not answer
because you don't definitely have the
information available but as a clinical
psychologist what do you think is mr
putin crazy
no
definitely not
no no you never want to underestimate
the people that you're at war with
that's a big mistake
there
and i see no evidence at all for
clinical psychopathology on putin's side
and he's
russians are complicated and he's
complicated he is by no means the worst
leader that russia has had in the last
hundred years not by any stretch of the
imagination i'm not standing up for
putin but i'm not going to casually
demonize him
you can't
take your simplistic understanding of
adolf hitler or joseph stalin which is
incomplete and then say well that's
putin it's like look
we're in trouble here
wars tend to spread and everyone thought
when the first world war started it'd be
a few months and then when it wasn't
they thought well we'll win easily it's
like no that isn't what's going to
happen
and the people thought the same thing in
world war ii
and they thought the same thing in
afghanistan and so
this is a localized ukraine-russia
conflict well first of all no it's not
it's a war by proxy of russia against
the entire west obviously now all the
world isn't on board with that but much
of the world is but not all of it
and so
you know
you might say when your sleeve gets
caught in an industrial machine and only
an inch of your sleeve is in you think
well i've still got my whole arm it's
like yeah for the next 10 minutes
but don't be thinking that that's how
it's going to be in half an hour and
it'll be an absolute bloody miracle if
this doesn't engulf us all
and there's a high probability of that
with all of that all that that entails
what would it mean for the russians to
lose
[Music]
like let's say that's what the west
wants we want russia to lose okay what
do you mean by that lose exactly do you
want the russians to feel
that they're going to lose
they have atom bombs
what is going to happen to a country
that's already paranoid and
misguided
if they also think they're going to lose
you think they're just going to lose and
we're not going to lose along with them
that's not going to happen
and so
we're playing with fire on and i think
i'm i've written an article
uh called the civil war in the west
because i think what's happening in
russia and ukraine is
a civil war in the west it's just that's
just where it started
russia is the west
and it's not just about post-soviet
territorial expansion it's not just
about oil and gas it's definitely about
those things but it's about way more
it's about
the stunning blindness and stupidity of
europe on the energy front
who didn't know this was going to happen
who's so blind
that they believed that making europe
dependent on russian oil and gas
for environmental reasons wasn't going
to produce this
and well we didn't know well if you were
a statesman and you didn't know that you
are so incompetent that it defies
comprehension because that's so
self-evident and so now we're in that
city
about responsibility and long
perspectives
and the practical perspective too you
know it's well you have these idiot
environmental utopian ideas well what
are you willing to sacrifice to that
well how about the energy stability of
europe okay great well now here we are
so
you know we're dreaming of a planet
where there aren't people to be
a cancerous growth well enough nuclear
exchange and we might just get that
so
we're playing with fire let's keep our
fingers crossed that we can still
survive yeah well next 100 500 years
one year
even one year yeah even one year there's
going to be mass starvation in the fall
there's going to be mass migration into
europe again obviously like the writing
is on the wall the un is already
projecting 150 million people in the
fall will face what they call that food
insecurity by which they mean
skyrocketing prices and famine food
insecurity famine
so yeah it's really not good